wir möchten nun noch einmal mit einer
geschichte aus england etwas hoffnung
machen es ist eine schöne geschichte
eines 99 jährigen aus großbritannien der
dort unglaubliche 15 millionen euro für
den kampf gegen korona gesammelt hat
runde für runde dreht tumor mit seinem
rollator im garten
er kämpft denn er hat eine wichtige
mission spenden sammeln für den
britischen gesundheitsdienst nhs kämpfen
gegen korona ich denke es ist eine
absolut fantastische summe wir hätten
niemals gedacht dass so viel geld
gespendet wird es ist unglaublich dass
die leute so freundlich waren dem
nationalen gesundheitsdienst diese summe
zu geben
insgesamt schafft der soldat im
ruhestand stolze 100 rollator runden und
sammelt mit dieser ungewöhnlichen aktion
13 millionen pfund umgerechnet 15
millionen euro ein
und vielleicht bin ich dafür
verantwortlich dies alles gestartet zu
haben
aber so war das nicht geplant ich war
einfach nur dankbar für das was sie für
mich getan haben
ursprünglich war das spenden ziel eine
summe von 1000 pfund
diese wurde bei weitem übertroffen am 30
april wird tom moore 100 jahre alt aber
das größte geschenk hat er nicht
bekommen sondern gegeben mit einer
spendenaktion die ans herz geht
damit rührte er nicht zuletzt diese
krankenschwester zu tränen
auch prinz william und herzogin kate
zeigten sich schwer beeindruckt von so
viel engagement
er ist eine ein mann spenden maschine
und wer weiß wie viel geld er weiterhin
zusammen bekommen wird es ist eine
unglaublich tolle aktion und man kann da
wirklich nur danke sagen für unfassbare
15 millionen euro die jetzt schon
zusammengekommen sind